he expects it to take officials some
time to adjust to these rules and maybe
there would be an overcorrectionist
durant shoved olynyk
after
well they're gonna take a look at this
look like
maybe something initially from olynyk
and then durant gave a shove
and
they are gonna go to the monitor
and review for
whether or not this is anything more
than a common foul on kevin durant
[Music]
i mean you see the forearm shove the
the part that you might take a look at
initially is the forearm i don't know if
he's
up near the neck of olynyk
before the extension
would be the one thing i would be
curious about
in flagrant two you get ejected and
speaking of
the other night our frank isola so
smartly pointed out as kevin durant said
that he was trying to hit the backboard
when throwing that ball
upon review the contact from kevin
durant has been
not necessary and excessive as a result
a flagrant two has been assessed
kelly olynyk will shoot two and kevin
durant has been ejected
[Applause]